بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين حمد الصابرين المجاهدين الثابتين
والصلاه والسلام على نبينا المجاهد الشهيد
وعلى اله وصحبه وتابعيه ومن جاهد جهاده
وبعد يا ابناء شعبنا العظيم المبارك يا
مجاهدين العظماء يا ورثه الانبياء وحمله
اللواء السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
بعد
83 يوما من بدء معركه طوفان الاقصى في
السابع من اكتوبر الذي وضع الكيان
الصهيوني على طريق الزوال والانكسار بقوه
الله وبعد هذا الصمود العظيم لشعب غزه
الابي العظيم الذي هو منا ونحن منه نعيش
الامه
واماله وبعد هذه الملحمه العظيمه التي
سطرها مجاهدو
ومقاومتنا فكسرت عن جيه العدو ومرغ انفه
ولا تزال في وحل غزه العظيمه صانعه الرجال
وقاهره الغزاه فان اعظم تحيه عسكريه
جهاديه لا يمكن ان يستحقها احد في هذا
العالم كما يستحقها شعبنا في غزه الذي
طالما كان سندا وظهرا وظهيرا وحضنا
لمقاومته التي هي منه وبه وله ومن اجله
فايه كلمات لا يمكن ان تفي شعبنا الاسطوره
حقه او ان تصف مجده وكبريائه
وعظمته يا امتنا يا كل احرار العالم اننا
انما نقاتل منذ عقود وصولا الى طوفان
الاقصى من اجل شعبنا وارضنا ومقدساتنا
واقصانا وسط خذلان رسمي مقيت من انظمه
ومجتمع دولي تحكمه شريعه الغاب ويتحكم فيه
صهاينه البيت الابيض هؤلاء الظلمه القتله
السحره الذين يريدون ان يقولوا للعالم بان
التاريخ بدا من السابع من اكتوبر متجاهلين
القتل البطيء الصامت لشعبنا منذ سنوات
طويله
بالتهوية صهاينه عندما وجهنا لجيشهم ضربه
القرن ودفعنا ثمن جرائمه وقلنا للعالم
باننا شعب يطلب الحق والحريه والحياه فلم
نكن يوما طلاب حروب ودمار وكان الاولى
بهائه الغرب والشرق ان يعترفوا بحقوق
شعبنا وينهوا الاحتلال لكنهم اثروا كسب
الوقت لصالح الاحتلال المجرم ليقضي على
شعبنا ويصفي قضيتنا ولكننا كشعب
صاحب حق وقضيه ورساله وكم قومه وفيه امينه
على هذه الحقوق واصلنا الاعداد والقتال
لاننا نعلم بان الحقوق لا تسترد الا
انتزاعا ولان كل شعوب الارض التي احتلت
انتزعت حريتها بالدماء والاشلاء وبالقتل
ولنا في فيتنام وافغانستان وجنوب افريقيا
والعراق والجزائر ولبنان وغيرها وغيرها
خير شاهد وبرهان يا شعبنا البطل يا امتنا
يا كل احرار العالم اننا في كتائب الشهيد
عز الدين القسام وبعد 83 يوما من المعركه
ومن العدوان ومن القتال نؤكد على ما يلي
اولا لا يزال مجاهدون في الميدان يتصدون
للعدوان على مدار الايام والساعات وقد
بلغت حصيله الاليات التي استهدفها مجاهدون
منذ بدء العدوان البري اكثر من
825 اليه عسكريه بين ناقله جند ودبابه
وجراف وشاحنه ومركبه ولا يزال مجاهدون في
كافه النقاط والعقد الدفاعيه يكبد العدو
خسائر كبيره في مناطق توغله ويحصدون ارواح
جنوده بالعشرات ويحققون الالتحام مع
الاليات والقوات على الارض ويسطرون ملحمه
تاريخيه وبطولات فريده ويختارون اهدافهم
ويخططون لضرب العدو في مقتل عبر استخدام
كافه الوسائل المتاحه من الاسلحه الرشاشه
والمتوسطه واسلحه القنص والقنابل اليدويه
والعبوات الناسفه والقذائف المضاده للدروع
والافراد والتحصينات وضرب تجمعات القوات
بقذائف الهاون والصواريخ كما نفذ مجاهدون
عمليات خاصه باعاده تفجير ذخائر غير
منفجره للعدو في الياته وجنوده وتفخيخ
بنايات وتفجيرها بالجن جنود الغزاه وتفجير
حقول الغام واستهداف ثلاث مروحيات للعدو
بصواريخ مضاده للطائرات خلال اليومين
الاخيرين وان حاله الضعف والانهاك والتخبط
لقوات العدو باتت حقيقه مشاهده واضحه لا
جدال فيها وهي تدعو كل احد في شعبنا
وامتنا لادراك ثاره من هذا العدو المتغطرس
الذي لا قبل لجنوده بمواجهه اصحاب الارض
والحق وال اراده وقد نشرنا الكثير والكثير
من الصور التي توثق استهداف مجاهدين لجنود
العدو والياته وهذا غيض من فيض من مجمل
عملياتنا على الارض ثانيا ان اولويتنا هي
وقف العدوان على شعبنا وانهاء حرب الاباده
النازيه الاجراميه التي يخوضها العدو منذ
12 اسبوعا ضد اهلنا من الابرياء المدنيين
بعد فشله في السابع من اكتوبر وتعزز
اخفاقه في الحرب البريه ولا تتقدم على وقف
العدوان ايه اولويه فنحن نشعر بحجم الالم
والمعاناه والظلم والهمجيه التي يواجهها
شعبنا امام العالم هذا العالم الرسمي
الموزع بين مجرم ظالم ومتفرد عاجز وهو
يشاهد قوه جبانه باغيه تصب جام حقدها
وتراكمات فشلها على الابرياء والامن وان
من افشل العدوان وسيوقع
مخذولا مدحورا هو صمود شعبنا ومجاهدينا في
الميدان وكسرهم لاهدافه وبناء على ذلك فلا
صفقات تبادل ولا غيرها من الطروحات يمكن
ان نقبل بها قبل وقف العدوان على شعبنا
بشكل كامل ثالثا انما رسخه يوم السابع من
اكتوبر وما تلاه في ذاكره شعبنا وامتنا
وفي العالم الحر وما اوجده كذلك في ذاكره
ووعي المحتلين الصهاينه سيبقى محفورا بعمق
ك علامه فارقه في تاريخ صراع شعبنا
التاريخي مع هذا الكيان المحتل وانما يقوم
به العدو على مدار 33 يوما هو محاوله
ازاله وطمس وتغيير هذا الاثر الهائل بصوره
انكسار الاحتلال وجيشه المجرم لكن كل شارع
وحي في قطاع غزه سيبقى شاهدا على عظمه
شعبنا وباس مقاومي في مقابل همجيه هذا
العدو ومن يقف وراءه من ادعياء الحضاره
الغربيه وحقوق الانسان ولقد فضحت غزه كل
منظمات ومؤسسات وهيئات الكذب والعار التي
تحمل سيف حقوق الانسان في مواجهه الشعوب
المستضعفه ولحمايه وتجميل الصوره البشعه
لقوى الظلم والاحتلال
والعدوان ختاما يا شعبنا المعطاء يا عنوان
الصبر والنصر انما يتقنه هذا العدو الجبان
هو التدمير والقتل محاولا عبثا ما يكرره
منذ عقود ايصال رساله ساله وقناعه لشعبنا
بعدم جدوى المقاومه لكننا نقول اننا مع
شعبنا في ذات الخندق سنبني ما هدمه
الاحتلال النازي وسنت سم مع شعبنا لقمه
الخبز وشربه الماء وسينكو يفشل هذا
العدوان بقوه الله عما قريب وسيخرج شعبنا
مرفوع الراس مكللا بالكرامه والمجد وستكون
كل قطره دم زكيه سالت من شهيد او جريح في
هذه الحرب قدسه شاهده على النصر والفتح
الكبير والتحرير القادم باذن الله ولتطمئن
يا شعبنا العظيم بانكم
بمقاومته الاقصى قد صنعتم نعش هذا
الاحتلال المجرم الزائل ولطالما كان سفك
الدماء البريئه علامه فارقه لتدمير وتتبيل
ودحر الغزاه وهذا ثابت وحتمي بنص شرائع
السماء وبنما التاريخ وتجارب الشعوب نسال
الله العظيم ان يرحم شهدائنا ويتقبل
جهادنا وان يشفي جرحانا ويضمد جراح شعبنا
وان يحرر اسرانا ومسر وان يثبت مجاهدينا
وينصر شعبنا ومقاومتنا وانه لجهاد نصر او
استشهاد والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته